also das ist doch
nichts zu suchen
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir
zimtschnecken auf zwei varianten weshalb
ich mir auch den hansa zu hilfe geholt
habe weil es kann nicht sein dass alles
alleine machen muss hier also wir machen
ein junge die helle variante ja und die
schoko variante habe ich mir gedacht das
ist ganz cool ist so und gibt schon
helle variante auf meinem kanal das ist
schon fünf jahre alt in alten küche in
unserer studenten aber ich hab mir
gedacht ist gebeten so dass ein plus
ultra grip mehrere rezept und heute
zeigt sich auch ein fluch gegen hefeteig
und haben sie hier ist deine schüssel
mit mehl ich schreibe euch wie immer
alle ganz genauen mengenangaben unten in
die
also immer
gedacht so mach ich es
deshalb haben sich auch viele gewünscht
das haben sie mal nach meiner anleitung
backt und das ist die perfekte
gelegenheit ich habe immer so viel los
ist nein wir machen jetzt den teig du
machst den hellen tag ich mache den
schock und die sind fast identisch die
angaben variieren ein bisschen und bei
mir kommt noch wacker kaum mit dazu
selbst ist da eine lehre schüsse wir
haben das komplette medicine unseren
großen schüsseln dann müssen wir mit
diesen kleinen schüsseln so ein bisschen
was wegnehmen das hat den einfachen
grund ein bisschen was sagt wie viele
frauen das ist aber wirklich nach gefühl
einlassung ein bisschen was so ungefähr
30 40 gramm das hat den einfachen grund
dass wir gleich damit so ein bisschen
besser spielen können damit der teig
nicht zu trocken wird und wie das
restliche mehl nach und nach dazu
gegeben also wir haben jetzt hier in der
schüssel ich hoffe man sieht's
kamerafrau sieht man alles so machen wir
ziehen eine mulde unsere hände sind
sauber noch deine hände dafür wir
verwenden jetzt trockenhefe ihr könnt
auch frische hefe verwenden die dann
einfach gleich in die milch bröseln
falls ihr dann frische hierfür nehmen
also muss morgen trocken über einfach
mit zum turnier mit ja eigentlich man
die mulde ausgleich machen können
ein bisschen fortan aber
trotzdem jetzt gehen wir milch dazu die
sollte im besten fall lauwarm sein das
hat den einfachen grund dass sich
dadurch der tag ein bisschen besser
kneten nicht damit halt nicht ganz kalt
auf die anderen zutaten trifft
mich in dem wohl gegeben
ja
nicht kriegen jetzt bitte gleich gleich
mag ich finde ich hatte was doch erstmal
dazu kommt jetzt noch eine super
sohn als nächstes dann unsere zerlassene
butter die solche nicht mehr ganz so
heiß sein und hatte gleich in die röhre
doch wollen wir natürlich nicht ganz man
gleich mal den tag übergeben haben sie
noch die reste ausschaut bekommen das
sind locker noch so drei gramm butter
die an am schlüsselanhänger
sowie meine mama früher wie man mit den
fingern rausgeschaut auf das ist kein
problem kommissar
wird nehmen uns zucker da hab ich ein
bisschen mehr zug auf 100 euch nicht in
den angaben er bei der ba cacaus club
noch so ein bisschen die süße habe
einfach meine tipps ist einfach klasse
da kannst du auch mal ein paar tipps
geben hat jetzt einen tipp habe sei klar
sagte tipp den ich hab dich gedacht
jetzt kommt der tat an dem wir kneten
müssen genau ich für meinen teil weil
haben sie nicht mehr wiedererkannt habe
vergessen cacau erfindung für mich das
nur dumm jetzt hätte ich vorher schon
mit dem eva mengen können die sind übrig
sich vor durch einnahmen dadurch so
schlimm das funktioniert trotzdem wenn
er bei euch so stück ich es dann könnt
ihr ihn aus malente - das geht trotzdem
auf jeden fall trotzdem habe ich etwas
vergessen mich nervös macht bei höchster
wird geknetet länger braucht
nein ich finde das einfach unten durch
daran kräftig hinterher denkt einfach du
bist eine küchenmaschine wie kannst du
dir zeit brachten essen tust dann muss
jemand der noch nie gemacht er hat noch
nie so was gemacht hat der dritte für
das ist schon immer dann muss man auch
mal durch finden hätte vor ausgezogen
hat einfach ein schönes gefühl dass auf
jeden fall knetet in den teig in der
schüssel bisher sich verbindet und jetzt
kommt genau dieser part nach und nach
mehr dazu geben bis der teig wirklich
schön fest ist aber nicht zu trocken und
ihr könnt auch gerne auf der
arbeitsfläche prüfe nun weiter kneten
[Musik]
so und jetzt einfach hansa auf der
arbeitsfläche ausrollen und zwar ja und
recht
herausnehmen
achdorf redaktion spiel ja genau hätten
wir das nicht gemacht und ich wollte
auch kein mehl nehmen damit das nicht
trocken jetzt redet ruhig aber rum und
dann packt ihn auf die arbeitsfläche
genau es wäre halt einfach zu trocken
geworden und jetzt einfach immer russen
machen nach hinten du brauchst jetzt
viel platz wir brauchen kein
zusätzliches wenn ihr euch unsicher seit
je nach arbeitsrecht könnt ihr noch ein
bisschen mehr drüber streuen aber das
eigentlich so scheint es gut und einfach
dünn aus von rechteckig
[Musik]
ja wir haben in der zwischenzeit schon
mal den teig ausgerollt sollen mal
gucken wie viele zentimeter das sind es
wird andere für die zuschauer
22 ja
ok
ich muss 11
23 bis 22 44 stellst du kommst doch ihr
körper sprich also 44 34 und lobby land
wir sind eigentlich schlau wirklich das
1 2 20 jahren ja das sind nochmals 1
440 x 32 cm müsste sich so genau nehme
ich weiß dass viele angriffe
42,125 also was haben wir gemacht wir
haben uns immer wahre mutter genommen
und dann richtig schön und bestrichen
das ist wichtig das gleiche umsatz in
zucker haften bleibt uns natürlich
geschmackssache und jetzt habe ich jetzt
unsere
mich jetzt hier noch zum braun ich lukas
müller natürlich ja genau und jetzt
müsst ihr einfach was raus und verstreut
wieder mit island genannte schlussläufer
einem level mit der häfen
wettkampfsports kopf so verstreicht
verstreuen überall ihr könnt ihr jetzt
übrigens auch überlegen ob in münster
dazu geht und da habe ich mir gedacht
nehmen wir heute nach weilmünster ihr
könnt aber auch haselnüsse nähen pk nyse
amex historische müssen nicht aber den
ich bin da ist es immer so stumpf vom
geschmack findet das sägewerk
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich den teig einmal
vorsichtig aufgerollt habe aber auch
schon hier meine backofen form gefettet
mit ganz viel butter wenn wir doch
nichts kleben bleibt das hier ist mein
erstes backblech das lege ich auch gerne
unten in die infobox und ich würde mal
sagen haben soll du hast jetzt die
ehrenvolle aufgabe unseren wunderschönen
strang jetzt zu zerschneiden
die kirche sollte mit der gewählten und
am besten immer so 3 cm dick so ungefähr
wie die bienen ja
kürzlich ihre vorzeichen dass rechtliche
form wieso man bei war dann kannst du
schneiden so schablone guter tipp für
anfänger nennt sich das x force trend
klar und dann ja gibt nicht andere
wollen so kaske du bist doch der krasse
dass ein tipp gegeben
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir den hellen tag
erledigt haben wir so gut gemacht
jetzt machen können dunklen teig und
einfach genau so fortfahren die beim
hellen teilzunehmen auch die gleiche
füllung und anschließend lassen wir das
zugedeckt beides und ich habs jetzt
schon zugedeckt ca 30 minuten ruhen und
dann verrate ich euch die backzeit
[Musik]
die wartezeit beträgt bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen
das ist super wichtig ca 25 minuten und
ich finde da fehlt dann jetzt noch so
ein richtig leckeres forsting und das
machen wir einfach in der zwischenzeit
so ich zeige euch jetzt die zwei
frosting varianten also eigentlich ist
es wirklich nur doppel raum frischkäse
vermischt mit puderzucker und vanille
extrakt und für die schoko variante
nehme ich jetzt hier noch bei kakao mit
dazu und dann einfach nur kurz
miteinander verrühren auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die häufigsten cinnamon banzer will ich
mal behaupten immer schon eingebüßt ich
habe für die s10 reingebissen ich bin
gestorben
ihr sohn längst wir eben es einfach
genießen hast du herrlichen im dunkeln
wie
war das also die schoko variante finde
ich heftig leute heftig was mit ein
bisschen bacau bewirken kann richtig
wirklich und ich und meine am besten
lauwarm perfekt deutsch ist
also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde
sie lauwarm wirklich am leckersten ihr
könnt ihn luftdicht verschließen ihr
könnt sie zwei tage lang aufbewahren und
auch nochmal erwerben hamann also so
schokolade
eingepackt werden er sieht man mal
kultur oder sowohl das ist wirklich nur
dieser richtig stark enthüllte ba kakao
tee schmeckt so intensiv wurde es
richtig kann ich ja noch mal von dem
verstörten ist also man kann etwas
auseinander zupfen das freut ich mir
geworden wäre ich muss nicht immer so ja
ich auch suppe die man ich weiß gar
nicht richtig rein zufällig heute wird
also berlin nicht nach macht wer hat der
hat was verpasst ich hätte auch nichts
zu suchen schmecke ich bin treffe das
ist auch heute sagen ich hab gesagt
vertrau mir wann ist so passend perfekt
mit dem sind mit dem rohr zog am morgen
ich würde sagen geht unten in die
infobox kopie also macht euch ein
screenshot kopie durch die zutaten macht
nach kommt zurück zum video das heißt
immer wieder aber ich möchte euer
feedback schreibt mir wie ihr wie den
geschmack findet das verdient ein herz
kommentar und das stück und wenn ihr
solche rezepte nicht mehr verpassen
möchte hinterland spätestens jetzt ein
abo wenn es nicht schon längst getan
habt damit man sagen
ich hoffe dass in dem wie trainiert du
bist das zu krass ist gekommen du hast
das heft die rezeptur ist krank rang
danke
ich hoffe ich habe ich habe euch enthält
und bis zum nächsten mal haben sie
gleichzeitig
[Musik]